moin meine
moin moin meine Freunde ich bin's Laser
Luca neben mir die wunderbare
bezaubernde
wir machen heute wieder eine nicht
lachen Challenge sandra hat sie mir
wieder nach Köln bemüht um mit einige
tiktoks anzuschauen
[Musik]
aber natürlich reich und traurig ich
würde in Baris Weinen nimm deinen
Apfelbaum Wein weinen ich würde in
dubaii besser als zu Hause
ich bin glücklich was ist denn wirklich
[Musik]
zu Hause
langweilig
ich bin glücklich
ich werde Apfelbaum wandern hier sitzen
bleiben sie mir genauso Papa als Skelett
Mama als Skelett der einzige Unterschied
zwischen Papa und Mama was ist der wenn
man Skelett ist ich brauche
der Busen die Silikon Dinger hängen dann
immer noch hier
immer noch bitte kommt mal in der
Podcast Folge
aber wie sieht denn der außen fort GT ja
ich bleib mal hier ein Bild ein
[Musik]
hallo kann ich dich kurz stören
ich bin eigentlich wegen dem WLAN da
also die haben gesagt und ähm
werden also es ist
[Musik]
heute nur Banger
ist kaputt das ist ungesünder als
Zigaretten Leute ich rauche seit einem
Jahr durchgehend lebt und ist noch
nichts
ist noch nichts
hier auf einmal 13 steht vor mir und er
sagt ich werde euch was vor guck dir
diese Server chainer Rap mal Rapha der
Papa Papa
[Applaus]
[Musik]
heute wird richtig herzlich gefallen ab
geht's ich wollte heute ein richtiger
kaufplatz leck mich heute er hat sich
ernsthaft LEDs darunter gebaut
wieder trainieren
kommt im Bus zu unter den besten Seiten
zeigen
der ist zwölf Rede von Martina ist alles
zu seiner Zeit hey jetzt mal eine Frage
ne aber wo leben eigentlich Hamster
außer wenn sie in einen Laden für 15 €
verkauft werden ich schwöre
[Musik]
als leisten
kennst du das schon klar also ich kenne
die Sprüche
immer gesagt
[Musik]
aber willst Du schon essen
das checke ich nicht
[Musik]
da ist mein Freund er tut schon wieder
Handy
mit meiner Hand
und er mit seiner Ohr und die
miteinander
wie kann man mit solchen Leuten mit
solchen Hunden chillen
okay
aber du musst auf jeden Fall
könnte
ich lebt dreimal zu sehr danach habe ich
herausgefunden dass er wohl die ganze
Zeit schon mit meiner besten Freundin
geschrieben hat und dann hatten sogar
was miteinander aber ich kann mich ja
jetzt nicht bei seinem besten Freund
rächen oder
Russia
[Musik]
Glückwunsch ärztlich Video geschafft es
ist endlich vorbei die Erlösung diesen
paar andere Videos verlinkt muss man
sich nicht angucken wenn man keine
Gehirnzellen verlieren will tschüss
[Musik]